Finland is one of the most interesting
markets in the world for somebody like
me because I'm unemotional meaning
marketing to me is just you know whether
it's outdoor or or Google or Facebook or
snapchat or Instagram or drawing on a
building or a flyer or television I'm
just unemotional I don't care I don't
love digital I don't like technology I
like attention because if you have
attention then you could tell somebody
what you're about in Finland per capita
the usage of Instagram and Facebook in
comparison to how much marketing money
is being put in there by the companies
in Finland is one of the biggest
opportunities in the world the citizens
of this country are using these
platforms tremendously the entrepreneurs
are building small little things the
problem is unlike America where the
entrepreneurs are winning so in America
every big companies in deep [ __ ] for
real like big companies like every
industry including Pizza Hut and you
know Domino's big trouble because
they're spending money on television and
outdoor and Direct Mail and little
startups are spending it on you know on
Facebook and things that nature and it's
happened overnight right what happens
here is entrepreneurs start winning in
Finland and then they realize how much
it works and they leave because the
markets not the biggest market so when
they see how big the arbitrage is on
Facebook they go to the Nordics they go
to Europe they go to the US they go get
funding in the US and startup what
that's done is created a very
interesting environment here in Finland
in my opinion which is the the big
companies are wasting money on
traditional stuff that got them here the
entrepreneurs are spending money
originally but then leave and you
understand why I'm so in love with
Facebook and Instagram right now it's a
marketplace there is no floor you know
unlike when you buy you know when you
buy an ad on Facebook if it doesn't work
well and try to spend a lot of money it
stops because there
most valuable thing is the person's
attention and bad advertising is bad for
them whereas when you run a bad print ad
or radio ad they'll take your money and
so to me there's an enormous opportunity
influencers I mean when I think about
fast casual or food space like the you
know I would probably map all 5,000
people that matter on Instagram in
Finland and pay them to give awareness
to your restaurants like I think the
think the arbitrage in this country
isn't that's why when you said all
locations here I perked up I was like
okay they're gonna be very interested in
what I have to say I mean I would spend
90% of your money on Facebook you have
to yeah and I'll tell you why because
it's a moment in time I'm this my energy
is based on resentment and regret I'm
very famous in my circles for building
my dad's liquor store in 1996 from 3 to
60 million with no money because I
figured out Google but the truth is it
should have been three to two hundred
million I didn't spend enough on Google
because marketplaces eventually correct
right now I know for $4 to $7 I can get
in front of a thousand people in Finland
on Facebook and they're paying attention
and in four years it's gonna cost me 80
and they're not gonna be paying
attention that's it
moments in time so not that I ever
believe spending 90% of any money on
anything is the right idea other than if
you're in the real estate business if
you're right about the beachfront
property in that moment you should buy
all of it it's okay not to do other
projects that's how I feel about
Facebook and Instagram right now in this
country that's exactly right and unlike
other markets where the entrepreneurs
and the venture capital based companies
fill the pipe and get the prices up
people leave here got it
that's the admits the opportunity that's
why I'm here
and that almost makes makes me think
that not that we're talking about they
know it's a concept should we actually
be considering or creating they know
nope it's a concept I'm just export in
the buying format than the product you
can produce it almost anywhere but you
wouldn't actually have a concrete space
you would just buy it and consume it
whole I mean the leap there it gets more
logistically and operationally I think
at its bare minimal it for example the
270 locations what's that called again I
apologize that the first pizza place so
CEO ket TI what do you spend on
marketing what do you spend your
marketing money on now to make that
company successful anything across the
board TV yep yep how much 3 million and
how much is TV get and then add a home
and radio and then digital and within
digital what is it no problem yeah to me
what I've seen over and over again
before I convinced the founder of the
board to move the big numbers usually
the 35% is where I focus first because
digital itself has a lot of bad stuff
you know in the way that I think you
know there's traditional digital and
there's 2018 digital most most of my
clients and a lot of what I see in the
world spend it on programmatic and
search and banner and and not enough on
so
and influencer and then there's the
question of are you doing sales what are
you doing branding because that's a
whole mix in itself what's the ROI is it
a transactional in-store foot traffic
sale delivery sale like how are you
breaking up brand that such a confusion
I've been surprised now going through it
the last ten years I'm surprised how
many people think they're marketing but
what they're doing is selling its sales
everything is based on well it costs us
nine dollars on Google to get this ten
dollar pizza we make three dollars
profit that's not good what's the LTV
that it it and they're not thinking
about the brand or the long tail or the
arbitrage of creative or all the other
variables that actually play out I don't
buy Nikes because of a sale I buy it
because it one brand and I think a lot
about that and then and then how do you
replicate what you're you know to me the
biggest opportunity for you is to figure
out how Facebook three minute two minute
one minute videos subsidized what you're
doing on television once you figure that
out I think you'd be stunned by the ROI
I think what you're doing on will
actually let me take a step back on
television are you doing what I see a
lot of qsr are companies doing are you
doing promotional advertising what are
you doing brand and what do you what
would you say is the 50-50 80/20 what
you've got tell you promotional brand
great so you know to me my belief is
that in this country specifically that
the amount of actual consumption of the
commercial is far less than the way it's
reported that you know that the math I
don't know if you're using an internal
mmm or how you're scoring you know the
success of your television but the most
sophisticated scores of television in
the US and Europe and other parts
they're they're making too many
assumptions of consumption of
commercials they're the reason they say
it
works is just a sheer amount of money
they spent you know I I had one friend I
asked him to just turn it off
and as didn't feel the effects of
business that much at all like to me I
have a lot of clients up
I had a meeting in the US and she says
well Gary you know I do this and she
goes Carrie but it didn't work
Digital didn't work television worked
like okay so I'm like you know I just
know that that's not true ninety-nine
out of a hundred times so I said let's
talk like I said to her in the same way
I like give me the details and she
smiled she's a nought she's amazing I
like her a lot she smiled so I already
knew I was in good shape she said okay
well I go what what did you do in the
first she said we we didn't work I said
how'd you how do you know she goes well
in the first quarter of this year we did
digital okay okay I go in the last
quarter we did TV so first I jumped on
the fact that liquor sales in the u.s.
50% of it is done in the fourth quarter
versus the first Club but that wasn't
even in I thought that was my aha
that was nothing compared to the next
thing she said she said we spent four
hundred eighty four thousand dollars on
digital in the first quarter they spent
8.5 million on television and I said
well you know it's very interesting how
people want to protect what they know or
what got them there I think Facebook
videos first of all a couple things
here's what I don't like about
television and why I'm obsessed about
Facebook first I think more people if
you spent ten million dollars a million
if you spent a million dollars on
television you spend a million dollars
on facebook video ads I think that more
people would actually see the Facebook
that's number one
like actually see it number two here's
the most important part there's a very
big difference between somebody who
makes a hundred fifty thousand euros a
year living in Helsinki and somebody who
makes forty two thousand euros living in
a suburb of how they're gonna associate
your brand and what value your pizza
brings to them the fact that television
only allows you one piece of creative
versus the fact that Facebook can target
very specifically and you are able to
make eight pieces of creative if you're
62 and you're 29 I have a funny feeling
your brand Kody means something
different your television is just doing
one message
so it's the flexibility of scaled
context it's how I think about it I'm
sure if let me just finish this and let
you up into it if I ran a workshop and
said okay let's talk about the
demographics and psychographics of your
customers we probably have seven or
eight meaningful groups eventually it
comes to small but the first groups may
be 18 to 23 year old males the second
one might be people that make 80
thousand a year some may be in first in
both but once you get to those eight if
you make two videos per those eight now
you have 16 assets and if you run your
media which i think is more efficient on
Facebook than tell it you see where I'm
going how I spend that million in a
different way so yeah related questions
about the budget so one of the problems
that we eternal matrix about is about
marketing efficiency if it runs into
with digital is this hard to do digital
a lot we have 95 percent brand awareness
in Finland
so we are issue is not going into areas
where we have higher for higher brand
new words availability opening hours
group dynamics dictate whether our
marketing is efficient or not if the
shops not open if it's too far
if the queues are too long on Friday
night it's very neighborly we can do
also we sell to half of Finland so we
sell to a lot of nurses and taxi drivers
and unemployed
it might be an opportunity from a
segmentation point of view but the point
is how do you do
social media marketing a lot I we know
that we can spend 50k on it easily and
be efficient how do we spend half a
million well I would already spend 1.5
million so that that's what he runs to
if it's it awareness our logo needs to
be everywhere our next message needs to
be heard that's fine
but we only have so many times of the
week when our market is going to be
tactically efficient and we have 95%
brandywine's well in a world where you
know a couple things there so that's
great I appreciate it so first of all in
a world where you of 95% brand awareness
if you're spending 75% of your 45% of
your marketing budget on TV brand you're
already broken it like period you've
already wasted almost half your money
right like if you really think about
that you're doing 75% brand on 45% of
your overall allocation on television in
a 95 percent awareness marketplace
that's come find like that that's
already just the wrong strategy number
two I would argue first of all scale is
not an issue for for Facebook it's just
not you know this is a very common
question that I reach like Facebook has
more scale it actualized consumption in
Finland than television does actualized
consumption Facebook when you add
Instagram with it
it has more scale so you could back to
your point if you want to do it which
based on what I'm hearing right now and
obviously I'm just picking up cues here
already doesn't feel like the right move
for you based on those metrics that you
just fed me but you could you know you
could spend an enormous amount of of
your allocation on Facebook the problem
to your point and so the smart point is
that $50,000 you may like the CPM costs
at $400,000 they make they're gonna go
up and you're not gonna like them as
much to me when they're actualized and
this is the most important part of this
conversation
they're dramatically cheaper than
remanent television because we're making
again like I said we're making too much
of some
on what's actually being consumed on
that 30-second spot Plus back to my
prior point the creative is not relevant
because you've got one vanilla message
for the entire country even more
exciting to me to your point and you you
picked up on it is if you're talking
about opening and closing and things of
that nature the number one most
effective thing I'm doing in the u.s. is
running one mile radius of Walmart's and
dollar generals and sonic restaurants
back to your business and Ruby Tuesday's
back to your business when you get into
one mile radius and things of that
nature you don't need to be wasting your
dollars and at the same level
you know what's incredible you the the
flexibility of a platform like Facebook
is you I think of it as day trading
versus long term mutual fund investing
you know you're talking about very
narrow things you could back at home be
turning the levers based on all sorts of
variables including if you're talking
about long lines and things of that
nature like I mean the amount of
granular flexibility that you can spend
your media based on the realities of
your day in and day out business is
pretty remarkable
including event marketing traffic
behaviors I mean pretty incredible
granular stuff you know we were just
that out there doing individual
marketing and I think that's where it's
all going now they're in a different
place financially and sophistication but
that is where it's going and I think
getting it from blunt Boop like
marketing to as close as you can get to
that individual basis they have a great
advantage that you and I don't have
which is like everything lives within
their ecosystem they see every behavior
that's something that you're not going
to be able to get to but on the flip
side if you're doing 10% of your
transactions now done by a mobile device
you're starting to pick up real data
you're gonna be able to do some pretty
remarkable things and lapsed users and
think of that name you could do some
pretty great stuff it's the back it's
the variable
yes now yeah but but here's the problem
it's not fun for us businesspeople I
don't like it
I hate being at the vulnerability of
creative it sucks it sucks to spend
$80,000 make something great and then it
doesn't perform unfortunately it is the
variable of success one Facebook YouTube
video for Dollar Shave Club created a
billion dollar exit where's the beef
just do it master cut priceless those
are real things the problem is it's all
the same rules of television apply the
problem is we have so much more data to
see what's working and not working so
we're holding the new world to an
accountability that we don't hold the
old world to yes that's one of our
things that we got more loyalty we get
the oil customers to buy at times when
we the queues on that long ie that when
they buy seldom they always buy on a
Friday night I decided at night when all
of the restaurants are busy anyway so it
sparked into so more we get more loyalty
maybe we'll get them to buy oh no no no
no way stale the other thing that the
other thing I apologize real quick
before you move on that to me is another
argument for Facebook you're able to run
more Tuesday Wednesday promotion because
what I love about it is when you have
flexibility you can map it to the
reality of your business for you and I
what's tough about some of these bigger
marketing things is it's upfront and
it's a god and there's no flexibility so
not only that I'll tell you what's
really amazing about your business is
whether it's a huge variable so again
you know to me when you understand your
business you can be spending it on you
know this is rare weather I here so very
excited you know but you know I think
one of the other things to think about
is is the flexibility I agree with you
like the Tuesday Wednesday Thursday
thing you know super fascinating to me
one targeting those you have first party
data now right you have those 10%
running them in Facebook and Instagram
to drive transactions Tuesday through
Thursday or I don't know how you built
your app or what the product is just
direct messaging and things I mean
that's incorrect I mean to me you want
100% mobile usage if you can help it
you should incentivize it at all costs
incentivize at all costs we're doing
this from my dad's liquor store now
we're basically pricing things
fundamental we are basically forcing you
to give us your data meaning I think
that you guys have the bill I would look
at your highest profit margin items and
come up with Tuesday Wednesday Thursday
sales predicated on them buying that
only if they do it with the mobile
demand just start I would start
jockeying your products to force
behavior to get them into the system
because that data is more valuable than
the profit margin I think that's right
except that we're starting to see a lot
more dr capabilities in facebook for the
most sophisticated yeah why because I
think that it's clearly based on what
I'm hearing the place that you got first
of all I'm there's there's yeah there's
a couple things one I think that there's
two things that are super interesting
you know again this is let me answer
this is intuitive and let me break it
down number one I think that there's 95%
brand awareness and then there's 95%
brand awareness you know there's there's
a there's assumptions here of our brand
awareness that I'm sure right when
they're at those numbers but there might
be a bigger Delta than we realize
understood
I believe that I think what's happened
over the last seven years and this by
the way I'm making this answer based on
coca-cola so I think that no matter how
successful you are you're not more
successful than coca-cola in America and
I think when we looked at their gen Z
and Gen X numbers they were there were
staggeringly surprising because I think
when you start thinking about a 25 year
old and in Finland you
be stunned how little they've ever now
they're gonna know it because you have a
lot of locations I get it but they may
not know it the way you think they know
it is number one and then there's
contextual brand awareness one of the
great things about 95% brand awareness
is 95% brand awareness one of the
terrible things about 95% brand winners
is 95% brand awareness meaning there's a
lot of people that have a certain point
of view on your product that is
entrenched they're just entrenched what
I'm I don't know I mean I'm shooting so
blind right now I'm trying I'm trying to
bring value but real quick on that my
friend just let me finish this your
ability to at scale back to the seven
segmentations change perception to
create more percentage of wallet and
better LTV is far greater than I think
most people realize padishah
is that we are 300 but there are some
about eleven or twelve hundred pizzerias
in finland which don't pay tax which is
single entrepreneur run you know shady
shady business and they they serve a
pizza with a sixty up to sixty percent
cost benefit because they don't pay tax
they procure their stuff to water from
wherever they don't pay you know
employer costs and that kind of stuff
and they will sell a pizza for four
ninety five ninety six ninety the only
way for us to tackle that market is to
introduce a coupon campaign where you
can get the rare pizza for seven ninety
which is just about rates even or if
even if that you know so that that's the
biggest market that's that's the biggest
challenge we're against criminals and
tax evaders the prices would not never
be able to even you know pay for that
cost not to mention a profit you know
that's a fact that we need something
there how would we use any engine to be
able to approach the kinds of people who
elect to go to do you have you
understand snotty have you guys debated
a different brand to attack that world
because i think the danger that you'll
go down if you attack that world is
diluting the brand right we want we've
all been stuck doing that i've done it
or my friends have done it
my competitors have done it the
dangerous thing that you just set up in
my mind that I'm sure you're trying to
think through thoughtfully is one
emphasized coupe awnings dilute a brand
to going there will dilute everything
else you're doing where you have more
margin I think one of the things to
debate is to rethink you know I know
you're thinking about them no and you've
got the Mexican thing you got a lot
going on here so I have a lot of empathy
but it's very entrepreneurial so that
makes it exciting for me you know for me
my natural intuition is to go very far
down the path of creating a different
brand to attack that market because I'd
be too fearful to completely collapse I
mean the amount of people who've lost
this game a much more sophisticated
bigger global queue SRS have been
destroyed by you know seeing the scale
underneath them being seduced by that
going down there and then giving up
everything on the above what happened to
the ltb of those people do you have any
sense Sunu well when maybe I
differentiate between you know who buys
it we just know that it's the price in
the fray
I'm just saying no I get ace the base
case like the baseline for our marketing
in years ago was 86 percent so our
marketing only explains if it paints
fourteen percent of our sales meaning
that you know where the shop is open and
where the shop is and what have you we
can deliver our cues are you know it
sucks so dominant art marketing that he
explains about 14% of ourselves but when
we have a coupon campaign we have an
injection of thirty to thirty four
percent which gives you an a some kind
of an idea of how big the challenge is
with the price I don't think it's a
challenge I think it's a decision you
guys have made to pander to short term
math now that may make sense because you
might be selling the brand to a PE for I
don't know what's happening but that's
no challenge that's the I would argue
that's the norm what you just described
is ninety nine percent of the businesses
I see because ninety nine percent of the
businesses I see half the pander to
short term math whether it's the
entrepreneurs ambition to take cash out
of the system or
Wall Street how can we do it couple ways
yeah a couple ways so first of all first
thing I to your point I would inject
immediately making the next campaign a
mobile only coupon I would force through
paper over time into your own system
because you'll be able to do so much
more so I would literally use paper
think about this this is funniest by the
way talk about eating your own dog food
literally literally yesterday morning I
approved a direct mail piece which I
rarely do to for my dad's liquor store
where it's only about getting them into
the mobile Club card which is in your
wallet you know the wallet app so I'm
literally you know giving the advice I'm
taking I would make the next big so how
often do you do that to me getting them
into the mobile device and and owning
all the data is so valuable that I would
you know again depending on your
finances depending on your long-term
finish line I would be willing to lose
money to get them in because once
they're in you don't have to spend all
the money on paper or digital ads your
remarketing within yourself the reason I
use the wallet is I'm using an app
called pop wallet so the club card is in
their wallet the way your flight in
their stuff is but it also gives me the
ability to text to text message them and
push notify you know you get a push
notification so I've amortize endowment
izing cost because I've got them in the
funnel and I got the first party data in
essence I don't give a [ __ ] like to me
it's especially cuz it's my family
business for my dad he's gonna keep it
until he dies so to me if I can amortize
it over 20 30 years right I think the
biggest piece of data that I don't have
sitting in this room is the macro
long-term financial ambitions whether
it's if you're not looking to transact
on that business Cody in the next five
years I would go so hard
and spend so much to just keep the
lights on but get all the first party
data in because you back to 95% and
owning the market and me I'm user was
and to me no matter how green you make
it and how green logos you introduce
what you have done recently my brand
awareness is from 10 years ago we can't
change it right that brand awareness is
there and it's cueing tell me tell talk
to me
you said killing and you said was talk
it out so what why were you why okay but
now you know cheap anymore because we
have other pieces and you have to try
and you're trying to make good
ingredients but I'm stupid I'm putting
you in the same box with all the guys
who are cheap it's a bad ingredients but
you're not cheap and you look green but
I don't know if you're green I'm not
going there
right so the brand awareness is actually
hurting you and so to me the biggest
thing is well what it what excites me
about what you're saying for me and as
we're breaking this apart is okay how
old are you
good I'm telling you right now you have
no chance of getting him on television
commercials that's getting half your
money like you just have no chance like
oh we have you guys looked at the OTT
numbers and Finland like like it's over
so to me that's exciting because I'm
like okay he's a 32 year old dude who
can afford it so we need to make
contemporary creative that's a two
minute like maybe it's like first of all
you have a very big asset him in a video
being like [ __ ] I know what you
think but let me tell you the truth that
it that has a way better chance of
changing his brand perception back to
the 95 percent what's good and bad about
it my intuition again as I'm building
blocks here of knowledge and context it
feels super right to me where I'm going
and I'll tell you why because it's
working for it's working for everybody
because what I think everybody's
struggling to comprehend is that it
happened not that it's
opening it happened it's over back to
like digital coupons it scares me too
because programmatic banners pop all
that stuff that can get very ugly I have
the same scrutiny of programmatic as I
do about you know television do people
actually see it forget the photo this is
business this is much more interesting
this is what they can visit what they
care about yeah three four years have
been really fast growing from the
bankruptcy into into being the shiniest
of the block and why did that help why
did that happen
well there are several reasons but I
mean you you get lost on the way how
much is a lot because we've we've
doubled the size see it within three
years locations are actually great why
average ticket sale I mean you get all
so lazy in thinking that the formula
that got us there of course success is
the biggest vulnerability I get it we
won't double it with the same medicine
brilliant already so that the marketing
class that will be discussing about
further for the coming year or the rest
of the year let me tell you one thing
that's great about this world as well
unlike a lot of other worlds there's you
don't have to do it up front so what I
would recommend is you know that's
what's so great you can the media can be
spent
very very very targeted and at low
numbers you can start with 10 and 12 and
19 thousand dollars for that week of
things that the ends really what's great
about your business unlike a lot of cpgs
is you're gonna see it you have you do
of that
you do if your foot traffic and the
average sale data so question organizing
if you go any change media agency as
your partner with social media
advertising versus doing it yourself
preference is always yourself you know I
mean you can but I would highly
recommend I mean the reason my agency is
having so much success is because it's
independent and it wants to buy brands
and businesses you know you gotta make
sure you like to me the answer is you
can first of all somebody has to know
somebody here has to know what the [ __ ]
they're doing because if the judge isn't
knowledgeable whether its internal or
external you're vulnerable so I would
say that's number one and I would argue
for both you two at least from what I'm
gathering here need to spend twenty
hours I mean it reading or watching
videos you have to be knowledgeable
about this communication in is the
number one most important thing that is
just the way people decide at the end of
the day so I think you know I think that
first it starts with that but my
preference is always internal it so
people always laugh that I give that
advice because I have a company but it's
better like why pay a Vig if you can do
it I think the problem is this skill
specifically the reason people are
struggling is it's such a valuable skill
usually people leave and so that's why
they've gone with agencies but I would
definitely not work with a publicly
traded pump it's owned by one of the
holding companies you're dead that I've
learned very obvious because they're
trying to make margin their publicly
traded so if there's an agency you're
working with but it ladders up to WPP or
Omnicom you're finished because they're
gonna spend your media to make the most
margin for themselves now for you I
think a lot of people you know it's
funny you're hearing it right yeah I
find it fun it makes me smile people
think what what it is is all over the
place
throwing things on the wall
schizophrenic I think you know what I
mean I think
practical like like to me it's practical
but I understand why it feels all over
the place because it's not the way you
know it feels different but to me it
makes sense for example in America I do
this all time like if you're top if
you're trying to sell something to an
African American family it's a good idea
to have African Americans in the video
that's what TV doesn't do like why can't
you guys make a video of two sisters
going to the store and then targeting
like women that have sister I mean it's
it's a lack it I would promise you this
if they spend twenty hours each and
actually understood what Facebook
actually does and how it actually works
you would never debate it any other way
it's literally the lack of education
that is holding back organizations from
it or other financial rationale like
your agency partners coming in and
showing [ __ ] data because they can't
make as much margin on Facebook as they
can on television yeah I mean I think
you know I to me SEO is table stakes
like it's important like you should have
it there but as you can see like even my
energy to me couple things with SEO one
it's on its last half because voice is
gonna kill it like search is gonna be
completely dismantled by voice over the
next decade
so that doesn't have anything to do with
what you care about what sales next year
next year but when you have 95 percent
brand awareness if you do as you say to
me search is not the place where you're
gonna get pay dirt you're probably
spending some there you're probably
organically doing your thing at some
level it's not the buying behavior of
what I see with pizza consumption
globally or other things what you need
is a back to his point you need a
perception change on that ninety five
percent or promotional oath that doesn't
you know as you said earlier you'll be
in deep [ __ ]
no I think what Facebook is is passive
content consumption which you said it
right search is intent based marketing
its intent when I can say Alexa sent me
a pizza this is why I want you to build
a brand because the next thing again I
don't know how long you're holed again
I'm trying to be very business here but
if you're holding a son for a while or
when no no pizza it sounds like
especially if you're starting it you're
going global in seven years
when across the globe people are saying
Google send me a pizza they better say
Google send me a no pizza because if
they say Google send me a pizza it's
either gonna cost you a fortune for the
lead gen ad or Amazon it's gonna own a
pizza company or have a private label or
you know there's a lot there all of it
all of it which is why building brand
matters my my concern is based on the
way you're spending media and based on
having the assumption of 95 percent
awareness I don't think your brand is
contextual or as contemporary as you
think it is to the 7 to 10 most
meaningful segmentations
that drive your business that would be
my intuition with the limited data that
I have and more importantly what I love
is it doesn't cost a lot to go out and
learn it and try it the thing that
you're not gonna like is the creative
get cost against it the media over in a
year you'll be blown away by the media
efficiency and your world's going to go
upside down instead of 80% of media 20
on creative you're gonna start realizing
it's more 50/50 the scary part is you
have the math to show you that of the
50% 80% isn't gonna work
which is gonna [ __ ] with everybody here
that cares about math but what you don't
see is that the 20% of that 50% done
right pays for all of it sure about
people not using Facebook but just using
this eg so messenger that's a great
question I would I Greek a thank you for
asking that
I think messenger is a really important
place for you to look at because you can
use AI and probably supplement an
enormous amount of what
doing from the ordering in the app
standpoint I think messenger is an
incredible product it's great but I'm
talking about advertising and how do you
go like heavy into like again how do you
spend five hundred thousand missing I
wouldn't because I don't think you can
yet because that's the question core
Facebook uses going down but it's not
yet but it's not to your point we'll
worry about that when it happens like on
a on you know to me I'm not worried
about 2020 it's why I even hesitate yet
to me again I said it earlier I'm on
emotional like if you told me Facebook
and Instagram and Twitter are gone
tomorrow I'm like cool what's where's
everyone where'd everyone go
I think the customer is
disproportionately educated and I think
that is the only thing that I would
spend time on I spend a lot of time my
business partner Steve Ross's they were
fourteen billion dollars he bought into
you know Michael Chang and a bunch of
Danny Meyer I'm very close to I own a
company called resi resy which is a
global leader and this play this piece
I'm very fascinated by here's my
punchline number one if you follow Mike
if you follow current trends you'll
always lose so for example if you ask me
the know if I have you said to me Gary
you've been adopted by us and now I
moved here and I live here and now I
have to open up one the first cut the
company I'd be working on right now with
the team is something that is not
healthy I think that I think what you
need to think about is the customer
knows everything but all customers don't
need the same things so I think we're
all going down the same path of healthy
this that and the other thing which
creates supply and demand it's the way I
think about marketing you know so I
think the white space is like in a world
that it's very complicated we have all
these issues it's been very fun for me
in the last year to watch mothers
care a little less if their kids having
something unhealthy to eat in a world
where they're worried about racism and
bombs and Courtney like it's funny how
the you know we get caught in our card
so I if I told you anything as you're
thinking about concepts it gets very
easy to get seduced by the current trend
without realizing that in four and a
half years that ball has moved and that
if you actually look at the data the
amount of unhealthy food consumed - the
amount of healthy food is not even close
and more importantly can you kind of
take ownership of of indulgence or
escapism I would say escapism with food
is very interesting to me which is like
it's okay to have a Sunday as a matter
fact it's a good idea you know stuff
like that brings true to me everybody's
trying to do salads and kale and [ __ ]
being in and it's great and by the way
it will continue to grow but everybody's
going there I think his points the one
that I you know it's always dangerous to
do a focus group of one but I will say
this if you ask me on paper what's
probably happening that is a lot more
real than you'd like to understand
especially in the face of success it's
where the opportunity is and I think the
biggest thing is your communication is
missing a lot of people because it's
blunt objects it's you know it's like
it's like why the u.s. struggled in
Vietnam if you drop bombs but everyone's
hiding and you're not getting them and
that's what that's how I think this is
you have to go yes and insect again the
key and I'll say it again it's the
framework my whole company is gonna work
on it's a kind of a mix of the old world
my old war that's what I grew up with
and the new world you sit and say how
many groups matter college kids you know
people of 40,000 income because it's a
low-cost food like you make you just
keep writing every group and then you
look at and go oK we've written 38
groups people they're like sports it
could be psychological it could be women
it could be demographics it could be 29
to 34 year old women you just write them
all of what you know and then you decide
how many are actually meaningful so you
have 49
of them you get it down to six and then
you make two three videos for each of
them
that is a very fertile opportunity for
you in this market I would I'm telling
you I would use him I would use him
because one of the other reasons I'm
here is entrepreneurship is a very quite
unlike other places like let's say a
Southeast Asia where it's outwardly on a
pedestal it's very intriguing to me the
psychology of the Nordics
entrepreneurship is on a huge pedestal
just quiet and so I think I just I
literally flew in slept and came right
here so I haven't seen much I mean I saw
enormous amounts of happiness on the
citizens faces because of the weather
the most amazing thing so far but but I
think he's a bigger asset and I think
you won't put him on a commercial but
putting if you if you make a video
targeting 25 to 35 year old fans of
entré fans of entrepreneurship
especially if he told the truth the
truth the truth 100% especially
especially a hundred percent it would
work especially if he addressed
something with truth I don't know what
your you know something you know I
wouldn't go like everybody's a criminal
route it not about the competition I
would take it insular and there's
something absolutely there or ask a
question again Facebook Instagram ads 25
to 35 year old male I would do the first
one people that are into
entrepreneurship if he just said hey
with technology now I can listen what do
you want from us what can we do
you just get free [ __ ] content like
you'll get free feedback they'll feel a
part of it and then if you guys did one
thing that everybody said one thing this
music this color this wallpaper this
influencer to show up at a store and you
showed that you listened and then if you
made watch how I'm doing it so he did
that
you got comments then you make a
two-minute video and it's a voiceover
our CEO went out and asked the citizens
of Hell of Finland what you need from us
and then imagine the video it's showing
him talking and then you responded and
sure through all the comments and we've
acted on it so you circle one where you
change the music and then it shows you
guys in a meeting with the the best DJ
in in Finland and he's talking or she's
talking and then you do like and then
you run that add that 2 minute video of
it's very meta you can build that's how
it works
[Music]